where that was my thinking phase this is
me trying to get popcorn out of my teeth
tell so how I active teenagers walk by
me hello
it is February which means it's almost
Valentine's Day which means why every
son reason Valentine's Day is my mic on
yes
sucks for you it's on just like me on
Valentine's Day watching some Liam
Neeson movies back to back
oh she's alone turned on what if that's
how I had strokes one of the cute and
fun things about Valentine's Day its
treats you know stuff you get to eat so
I thought that I would show you guys
some really cute and easy Valentine's
Day treats that I came up with in my
head on my own after looking at
Pinterest for a long time okay so the
first thing you're going to do is take
some standard cake mix from a box and
just like your boyfriend Brian you're
going to struggle to get it to open up
and then one day it'll kind of open up
and be slightly underwhelming and now
it's time to crack in the eggs and look
you've cracked eggs before plenty of
times and in chat rooms but Brian thinks
it's best to crack eggs with one hand
and at first it's really exciting but it
mediately becomes kind of but
immediately it becomes more difficult
and uncomfortable and really stressful
and you don't like it as much as Brian
turns out it's like the egg shell you
teach yourself that it's just better if
you throw your feelings away then we're
going to add our oil and our water and
now it's time to mix the batter and even
though you wanted that Cuisinart mixer
Brian thinks it's best to do this part
by hand he doesn't think it's as
rewarding to use vibrators I mean mixers
hand mixers for the kitchen and he's
right look how rewarding this is once
our cake batter is all mixed up we're
going to take some super cute red food
coloring and we're going to put them
into our cake batter to turn it paying
and just like what brian says about
honesty in a relationship a little bit
goes a long way because look just as our
couple drops our batters already pink
and I know it's hard to tell but trust
me it's like when I try to get my
girlfriend's to see that Brian's
actually
a good guy and they were like the he's
on your lawn when you didn't get them
that PlayStation and I'm like you have
to look closer and then we're going to
take these super cute heart-shaped
baking molds and fill them about halfway
with our cake batter and this parts
going to take a second it might seem
tedious or monotonous and you might stop
to think about monotony as a whole and
how the monotony of the fact that you
and Brian only have missionary style sex
is slowly killing you but then we're
going to take our malls and we're gonna
put them in the oven for just like a
guesstimated amount of time it's like Oh
Brian always says there's no way of
knowing how long you guys are going to
be together so while our heart-shaped
cupcakes are cooking we're gonna take
some foam donned which I got at Michaels
and bond on it's just a fancy word for
icing and we are going to make some
decorations for the cupcakes the first
thing you do is roll out the fondant and
then you have to keep rolling it like
that stupid [ __ ] limp Biskit song
that Brian always listens to a key rule
rule what that doesn't mean then when
it's thin enough I'm going to start to
cut my shape and I thought it'd be so
cute to cut out an arrow to put on top
of the cupcake so it looked like you
were pointing at yourself like who loves
you me so after an undetermined amount
of time take your tiny cupcakes out of
the oven and realize that they look so
much like hearts it's crazy it's like
identical to the way love is perfect
so like Brian once they have cooled down
from being so hot added and you realize
that they're not what you want them to
be just do what your mom always told you
to do change them in this case I'm using
a small knife to cut the tops off to
make them look more like hearts then I'm
going take some vanilla frosting and use
it as glue to attach our little love
arrows or Cupid arrows duh oh my god
they should be keep it arrows like Brian
always says I'm a bee idiot but I'm
gonna take some of this decorative
edible marker stuff that I found also at
Michaels and I'm gonna use it to draw
some really cute quirky Pinterest
designs on my arrows before I put them
on my cupcakes and there you go our
final product are cupcakes with a cupid
arrow
on top so that Brian will really know
what you want this Valentine's Day a
wiener I mean love for this next video
cheat we're going to use the item that
you're now EX Brian used to call you a
loaf of bread you're going to take two
slices of bread and then I'm going to
use this heart-shaped cookie cutter that
I got because I'm barely hanging on I
mean creative and I'm going to cut to
heart shapes out of each piece of bread
I mean one heart shape out of each piece
making two pieces total so you do know
how to do math Brian didn't know what
the [ __ ] she was talking about his
eyelids look like cankles then you're
gonna take a second to look at the
scraps of bread and wonder what you
could possibly do with them and they're
gonna throw away because they remind you
too much of yourself so we're making
your standard peanut butter and jelly
but to give it a twist once you have
your peanut butter and jelly on both
sides of the sandwich we are gonna take
an old love letter that Brian wrote us
and we're gonna sandwich it in this
sandwich hey Brian what's wrong you are
funny and anyway his penis look like a
sword made of balloon and there you go
you have your final peanut butter and
jelly sandwich so now when Brian comes
over to collect the last of his
belongings you can serve this sandwich
to him so that he can eat his king words
you see this sandwich is a play on words
because jelly is common street jargon
for the word jealous and you have every
right to be jealous and you found out
you was taking his balloon Wiener in
church is about Hawaii you are day
well there you go there with Valentine's
Day treat ideas I hope that this was a
treat for your brain I hope you have a
good Valentine's Day remember you can't
spell Valentine's Day without leave
goodbye
I don't know like a bad Valentine's Day
a corn kernel will not leave I'm using
my tongue so much here's a hypothetical
me Liam Neeson a hot tub no regrets
still read to liked this video if you
liked it and leave a comment down below
on your favorite Valentine's Day treat
and what you're doing for Valentine's
Day because I care also subscribe to my
channel so that we can finally be in a
committed relationship can't smoke
committed relationship without real spit
okay now I should go for sure